he is doing very very well we have
numbers coming from companies that are
beyond expectation the tax cuts are
working very very well so we're very
proud of the economy job numbers are as
good as we've ever had and more people
are working right now than ever worked
in our country before we're doing really
well
I'd like to congratulate Bibi Netanyahu
it looks like that race has been won by
him it may be a little early but I'm
hearing he's won it and wanted in good
fashion so he's been a great ally and
he's a friend I'd like to congratulate
him that was a well thought out race I
could tell you but it looks like Bibi
has won that race go ahead Jim say it
so the fact that bb1 I think we'll see
some pretty good action in terms of
peace look everyone said and I never
made it a promise but everybody said you
can't have peace in the Middle East with
Israel and the Palestinian I think we
have a chance and I think we have now a
better chance with Bibi having won yes
play major call it major
[Music]
no there is no law as you know I got
elected last time with the same issue
and while I'm under audit I won't do it
if I'm not under audit I would do it I
had no problem with it but while I'm
under audit I would not give my taxes
there's no law whatsoever now I will say
this I would love to give them but I'm
not going to do it while I'm under it
it's very simple remember I got elected
last time the same exact issue with the
same intensity which wasn't very much
because frankly the people don't care
what I have done is approximately a 104
page summary and really in great detail
of assets and values that nobody wants
to go over that because it's so good I
built a great company one of the best
companies I have some of the greatest
assets in the world I did a good job and
now frankly I don't care about them I
only care about the United States but I
have no obligation to do that while I'm
under audit and no lawyer would tell you
to release your tax returns while you're
under out of it
I think that the whole asylum rules laws
and regulations have been taken
advantage of by people that are very bad
people in many cases these are the
people running the cartels they gaming
the system they happen for years the
only difference is our economy is now so
strong that more people come up we have
done a great job as the border with bad
laws it's very important that the
Democrats in Congress James these
loopholes if they don't change them
we're just going to be fighting now the
other thing we've built a lot of wall a
lot of walls and it's new world you know
when we rip down an old wall and then
replace it is called a new wall and
that's what we've done a lot of wall is
going up and every place we build the
wall it's less and less but the power of
the economy it's like a magnet it's
bringing more people than we've seen in
a long time
major
well the mullah reports interesting
after 35 million dollars with 13
increase for 18 angry Democrats people
that truly hated Donald Trump truly
hated Trump they found no collusion
whatsoever with Russia but I could have
told you that and so but most people and
so good of everybody that voted for me
which was a lot of people so after
wasting all of this money and all of
this time with people that were haters
people that worked on the Hillary
Clinton Foundation people that were
absolutely haters of Trump they found no
collusion what has been found during
this period of time are the illegal acts
of getting this whole phony
investigation started and hopefully
that's where people are going now that's
where people are going and it's very
interesting it was an illegal
investigation major it was an illegal
investigation
it was started illegally everything
about it was crooked
every single thing about it there were
dirty cops these were bad people you
look at McCabe and Co me and you look at
Lisa and Peter's struck these were bad
people and this was a attempted coup
this was an attempt to take down of a
president and we beat them we beat them
so the Muller report when they talk
about obstruction what we fight back and
you know why we fight back because I
knew how illegal this whole thing was
with the scam and what I'm most
interested in use me what a most
interested in is getting started
hopefully the Attorney General he
mentioned it yesterday he's doing a
great job getting started on going back
to the origins of exactly where this all
started because this was an illegal
which son and everybody knew it and they
knew it too and they got caught and what
they did was treason what they did was
terrible what they did was against our
Constitution and everything we stand for
so hopefully that will happen there is a
hunger for that to happen in this
country like I have never seen before
including all of the millions of people
that voted for me what they did was
disgraceful there's never been anything
like it in the history of our country
well I like Herman Cain and Herman will
make that determination Herman is a
wonderful man he's been a supporter of
mine for a long time he actually ran a
very good campaign and that's up -
Herman Herman is you know he's already
sad but one of the Fed boards and he's
just somebody I like a lot as to how
he's doing in the process that I don't
know you go through a process but Herman
is a great guy and I hope he does well
now Stephen is an excellent guy he's a
wonderful person people don't know him
he's a wonderful been with me from the
beginning he's a brilliant man and
frankly there's only one person that's
running it you know that is it's me I
have not seen the mullah report I have
not read the full report i won no
collusion no obstruction i won everybody
knows i won and the pros knew it was
illegally started the whole thing was
illegal I have not read the mullah
report I haven't seen the mother report
as far as I'm concerned I don't care
about the mullah report I've been
totally exonerated no collusion no
obstruction and I'm off to dealing with
China I'm off to dealing with North
Korea I'm off to dealing with Venezuela
and all the problems in this world I'm
not worrying about something that never
ever should have taken place
I did not see what happened I did not
see what happened to Kansas Helen
excuse me I did not see what happened to
Kendall
well I think that's a terrible thing I
think it's a terrible thing that he
would do that I find her to be a very I
know her I think she's a fine person a
fine young woman and I think that's
disgraceful that they could say
I don't hear you
chiller
I respect him I like him and he's
somebody that you know I have a lot of
regard for
[Music]
my finances are very clean I don't think
there is an investigation if you say it
I don't know but I don't think there is
an investigation my finance is immensely
[Music]
good happens we'll make a determination
right now he's the man he's doing a
great job Kevin okay
thank you see objection
[Music]